[Musique]
étrangère
Lander sauve la réputation du Wisconsin la
musique est vous savez
version unique privilège Rhinelander a United
prospérité
critiques
[Musique]
Horizon
Je pense que c'est là-bas,
c'est dans les bois lors d'une de mes
promenades nocturnes à proximité ici alors que je passais
devant  Dans la zone marécageuse, j'ai été arrêté net,
puis je me suis rendu compte que je regardais
une créature très unique, voire unique
en son genre.
Il y a même des rumeurs au début selon lesquelles il
mangeait de la chair humaine.
[Musique]
fille je
viendrai sur l'œuf
[Musique]
il est noir il a des cornes dans le dos de grosses
grosses griffes une corne sur son poignet nous
recevons occasionnellement
des Lanes de certains citoyens appelant
à propos de la mystérieuse créature
étrangère
cet objet se rapprochait et voici ceux-ci  les
yeux rouges, les
griffes ont arraché le ventre de n'importe quelle bête, c'était
si effrayant que des cornes coulaient sur son dos.
Je veux dire, c'était juste cette bête qui
sortait de ce bûcher. J'ai en fait
cherché tout le jour pendant 40 ans
et le Hodag est sorti en trombe.
les buissons l'ont mordu en deux
organismes
il y a beaucoup de livres écrits sur
l'œuf entier,
la plupart d'entre eux sont quelque peu historiques
sur un autre Hodag lors de la première
découverte du Hodag mais tous
auront un chapitre sur les
observations modernes du Hodag
et le Hodag est apparu dans les
médias à divers endroits, il y a une
émission pour enfants qui avait un épisode entier basé sur
le salon étranger du Hodag
[Musique]
en 1896 soi-disant
il a été dit que Gene Shepherd
avait capturé le Hodag et  comment l'a-t-il
capturé, il avait une perche en bambou de 10 pieds,
il avait une énorme éponge imbibée de
chloroforme et il a réussi à savoir
quand le Hodag était dans sa grotte et il
s'est frayé un chemin jusqu'ici avec cette éponge
et ce chloroforme et a obtenu le Hodag.  pour
aller dormir, puis il a amené les
citadins là-bas, l'a ramené
chez lui et l'a montré pendant des années et
des années, l'a amené aux foires régionales
et a gagné de l'argent en montrant que le
berger Hodag vivait en Rhénanie
la zone climatique la géographie la
géologie de la région  tout se prête à
une créature comme l'œuf entier qui
prospère une année existante, il mesure sept
pieds de long
[Musique]
sept pieds et demi de long, on nous
rapporte environ 12 à 1 500 livres, donc ce
n'est pas quelque chose que vous pouvez cacher dans les
bois mais  son camouflage a été,
disent-ils, très bien Jessica Gene shepherdo La
[Musique] étrangère
Rhénanie
[Musique]
est
une
[Musique] il y a
eu des gens qui ont
raconté des histoires qui,
à mon avis, ne peuvent être interprétées que comme des
observations du hodek donc oui  nous avons eu
des jeunes et des personnes plus âgées
qui jureront que ce qu'ils ont entendu et
vu dans les bois devait absolument
être un hodek
[Musique]
merci
Wisconsin
the Wilderness Queen
Metro cap ou Direction visite
ORS
Shepherd
était un  l'homme qui a découvert un œuf entier et
non un marais juste au nord de la Rhénanie, maintenant
le Hodag était euh quelque chose qui n'avait
jamais été trouvé auparavant c'est
[Musique]
c'était une créature unique et Jean
Shepard a décidé qu'il devait gagner de l'
argent avec cette créature, il  trouvé et
il a donc commencé à le montrer dans les
foires du comté au tournant du
siècle, des années 1800 aux années 1900 et il
l'a montré là-bas avec beaucoup de succès et
s'est fait gagner pas mal
d'argent en le faisant, mais Jean Shepard
était un vantard et un ivrogne.  un coureur de jupons
et il est mort fauché et a divorcé il
ne savait tout simplement pas comment gérer son argent
emplacement
s
[Musique]
tournez-le de cette façon Matthew
assez vite et Matthew êtes-vous de la
région
êtes-vous d'ici non
Steven's Point hein, savez-vous  le
Hodag
oh tu aimes toute la journée
ouais
Jerry Tom la convention
[Musique]
c'est que
j'ai mentionné sur cette île que
cela pourrait être la zone où une journée entière
serait citée
eh bien, il est possible qu'il y ait de l'eau et le
hodak apprécie quelques palourdes et
des tortues de boue et quelques serpents d'eau
mais il aime les belles zones marécageuses
et je dois vous dire qu'un jour je me
promenais dans une zone assez
marécageuse et en me promenant dans les
bois,
je profite de la belle soirée qui va
être une soirée comme aujourd'hui et j'en
profite je profite du calme et de la
tranquillité de la promenade et tout d'un coup je
suis stoppé net dans mon élan comme mort
dans mon élan
car une odeur m'assaille le nez
une puanteur qui pourrait  seulement être décrit comme étant
si fort qu'il chasserait une mouffette d'un
tas d'intestins. Je veux dire, c'était mauvais. Je me suis
arrêté.
J'ai avancé tranquillement et prudemment
et en contournant un virage,
j'ai pu voir cette apparition
traverser les bois parce qu'il y avait un
peu de brouillard.  cette nuit-là et le voilà qui
descend le sentier
et à mesure qu'il se rapproche, je remarque que ses
yeux brillaient de vert,
que son nez était rouge
et alors qu'il apparaissait de plus en plus près tout d'
un coup avec une agilité de chat, il a
sauté sur une bûche.  juste devant moi
et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai vu les énormes
griffes si grosses qu'elles pourraient arracher le
ventre de la plus grosse bête
quand j'ai vu les cornes courir le long de son
dos se terminant par une poignée de ces
pointes d'aiguilles au bout de son  queue
et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai essayé très soigneusement de
ne pas bouger du tout par peur de
ce qui pourrait arriver.
J'ai fouillé dans ma poche supérieure et j'ai
sorti mon iPhone
et j'ai commencé
à prendre une photo aussi silencieuse que
possible, puis sans faire de bruit soudain.
mouvements, je me suis éloigné très soigneusement
de cette créature, je
l'ai fait sortir de là
[Musique]
Jerry encore un
Lander étranger
[Applaudissements]
calme je ne sais pas j'aime voir
ce que tout peut sortir quand tu es juste
assis là et
bien c'était un  beau et ensoleillé dehors, c'était
vers Dusky, même si j'avais fini de
dîner et je n'avais pas de devoirs alors
j'ai décidé d'y aller et de m'installer dans
mon arbre préféré comme je le fais à chaque
fois
et je l'ai vu,
il était noir
euh, il y avait beaucoup de pointes, il en avait deux sur la
tête, puis au moins 15 qui descendaient
dans son dos et pas mal sur sa queue.
Les griffes étaient, je ne sais pas,
probablement aussi grosses sur chaque patte,
il en avait environ trois.  eux et puis un
comme sur son dos là-bas euh c'était
effrayant
donc comme si je me suis un peu figé et puis je me suis dit que je
devais sortir d'ici,
je sais qu'il y avait quelques ours
là-bas alors quand j'ai sauté du
arbre, je voulais m'assurer que ce que j'avais
vu était correct et quand je suis descendu là-
bas, c'était définitivement un hotig qui hurlait des
narines rouges, c'est Dench était horrible
et euh, je savais ce que j'avais vu et j'ai
bien couru, c'est à ce moment-là qu'il aime sortir.
je chasse donc je me tiens à l'écart des
marais la nuit
[Musique]
J'ai écrit sur le Hodag parce que je suis d'
ici parce que c'était une façon d'
incorporer des histoires que je sais que je suis un
Hodag, ma famille remonte au recensement de 1890
et aux Rhénans et  un hodag a fait partie
de ma vie toute ma vie mes parents étaient
hodex ils sont allés au lycée ici mes
grands-parents
j'utilise tout je prends l'essentiel
de l'histoire de Hodag et j'ajoute des choses qui
pourraient être vraies nous avons une histoire sur les
funérailles de shorty  Matusack, il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'histoires connues, d'histoires vraies
sur ce qui est arrivé à certaines des
victimes du Hodag, mais Shorty Matusik
a été victime du Hodag, il était
pompier dans le train et le train
s'arrêtait dans une petite ville appelée
Roosevelt.  le côté nord de la
chaîne de la lune
donc le feu rouge était éteint le train s'est
arrêté shorty matusek était le pompier il n'y
avait personne à la gare c'était une
nuit sombre et brumeuse il a quitté le train
ce qui était son erreur il a regardé pour voir
ce qui se passait  le long des voies
et le Hodag est sorti des
buissons en courant, il l'a mordu en deux
juste comme ça
maintenant, la seule chose à propos de ça, c'est qu'il a dû
être enterré et bien sûr, le père
Himmels a dû venir et dire d'accord, nous
pouvons avoir une ouverture  cercueil mais ce n'est pas
souvent qu'on a le fond du
cercueil ouvert bien sur c'est tout ce qui
restait à assortir il était le fond alors ils ont
mis ils ont pusé un petit
rideau de satin en haut pour qu'on ne puisse pas s'agglutiner
là et il portait  de nouvelles chaussures et
tout le monde est venu aux funérailles de Shorty
Matusek mordu en deux par le Hodag
[Musique]
c'est un secret de famille on ne peut pas
vraiment dire grand-chose
que tu sais où voir toute la journée
donc tu sais que certaines personnes pensent que c'est peut-être
un  canular mais c'est un secret de famille, ce
serait comme dire où se trouvait votre
Blueberry Patch préféré, vous ne
parlez jamais de cette
inspiration de l'éternité de Rod umloft,
notre famille viendrait dans le nord du
Wisconsin,
nous aurions des feux de camp la nuit, nous pourrions
camper ou
rester  la cabane et mon oncle, il
adorait raconter des histoires de fantômes, je veux dire, il
était du genre à nous raconter des
histoires vraiment effrayantes, puis à nous emmener dans un
cimetière et à nous faire marcher dans
le cimetière,
donc il y a ce bruit dans les bois et
ça  l'objet se rapprochait et voici
ces yeux rouges
et à mesure qu'il se rapproche, il fait ces
bruits et il sentait mauvais, pas comme une
mouffette, mais il y a
ces
cornes qui sortent de son dos et il fait
ces bruits vraiment étranges et nous avons eu
vraiment peur mais nous avons pensé  un peu comme si,
je veux dire, oncle Dick faisait toujours
ces blagues,
euh, mais on pouvait dire qu'il
ne s'attendait pas à ça
et il a ramassé une pierre et l'a lancée sur
cette créature et vous savez, en y
repensant, je pense que ces yeux rouges n'étaient qu'un
reflet de  le feu de camp
mais cette image dans mon esprit tu sais j'étais
tu sais assez jeune six sept mais c'était
ma première expérience de toute la
journée il y a environ
dix ans je faisais de la raquette et
le soir j'ai vu un groupe de hodags
pas pas près mais  ils étaient, il y avait
beaucoup d'arbres morts et j'étais en haut d'une colline
donc j'étais juste incroyable parce que
vous savez, j'avais entendu des histoires sur le
Hodag mais vous sauriez que les gens en
parlaient juste d'un mais ici, vous savez,
un groupe d'entre eux  et je ne savais pas
si je devais l'appeler un troupeau d'œufs chauds ou
un paquet d'œufs chauds, mais c'était il y a environ
10 ans, bien sûr, j'ai dû
peindre que les
installations de Rod
sont également étrangères
[Musique]
Appareil photo rhénan
Lander Tucson étranger, c'est
bien ce que j'ai trouvé pendant tout mon séjour ici,
c'est qu'il y a vraiment deux types de gens
quand il s'agit de croire au Hodag, il y a
ceux qui veulent juste y
croire et il n'y a absolument pas que
ce soit amusant, c'est un  c'est une
créature merveilleuse, vous savez, partagez des histoires sur
euh et puis le deuxième type sont les
gens qui essaient juste de vous tromper les
yeux.
Je suis sceptique donc je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de
preuve qu'il existe, c'est
tout  des anecdotes si vous commencez à chercher des
preuves Si vous commencez à regarder la
possibilité scientifique qu'un Hodag soit
là, euh vous n'aurez pas
grand-chose sur quoi vous appuyer si vous y réfléchissez,
le genre d'une des grosses erreurs avec
le Hodag le  l'histoire dans la mesure où
la réalité est qu'il n'y
a toujours eu qu'une journée entière et
donc maintenant, pour qu'il y ait encore un œuf de hode qui
court partout aujourd'hui, il
faudrait qu'il y ait un animal d'environ
170 ans
si vous regardez simplement les
preuves scientifiques de ce qu'il faut à
une espèce pour survivre et le fait que
nous n'avons pas de photos d'elles, vous pouvez
additionner des choses comme si c'était un grand  créature,
elle consommerait une quantité incroyable de
calories pour survivre, probablement l'une des
histoires les plus célèbres que Gene Shepherd a
inventées lorsqu'il parlait pour la première fois
de toute la journée, c'était la puanteur de
la créature
et à l'automne, nous avons des chasseurs qui
sont tout simplement complètement  remplissant toutes les
terres autour de la Rhénanie qui
chassent et bien que vous sachiez peut-être qu'un
Hodag peut se cacher sous un buisson pour se
cacher, mais s'il pue tellement que
vous pouvez le sentir à moins de cent mètres,
vous penseriez que tôt ou tard quelqu'un le
ferait  dis hmm j'ai senti un Hodag je vais
le retrouver je vais le prendre en
photo et pourtant je ne vois pas de
photo ou qu'est-ce qu'il y a ce sont des fonctions de scènes
[Musique]
photo
hélas,
en rentrant à la maison,
ma batterie était morte
pendant que je cherchais le chargeur, mes
chats ont décidé d'utiliser le téléphone comme un
kickball et ils l'ont brisé au-delà de toute
croyance
mais je l'ai vu,
c'est réel,
je n'ai eu qu'une seule coupure,
vous en trouverez  des photos que Gene
Shepherd lui-même a prises du Hodag, des
citadins debout attaquant
le Hodag et ainsi de suite, mais vous savez,
c'est une créature assez raide,
elle semble être
parfaitement assise là,
donc
je ne suis pas sûr à quel point vous êtes vraiment  Je veux
prendre cela au sérieux, il était le farceur,
il était le père de cette grande farce
et donc je doute qu'il aurait
admis exactement que c'était un canular, mais il y
a certainement eu un certain nombre d'
histoires qui l'ont découvert,
vous en savez plus vous  Regardez Gene
Shepherd, plus vous découvrirez que
ce type aimait faire des farces, c'était un
farceur, il était, vous savez, un
homme remarquable, il était un très bon arpenteur du
bois, un grand parleur et un grand
conteur, mais il est aussi l'un d'entre eux.
des gens et nous connaissons tous un de ces
gens dont on ne peut pas dire si la moitié des
histoires qu'ils racontent sont vraiment
vraies.
Gene Shepherd était un farceur,
un farceur et il aimait se vanter, mais il
aimait aussi promouvoir le domaine dans lequel il se trouvait.
Onasis déforestation
[Musique]
un CV rhénan
Gene Shepherd,
il a eu l'idée d'essayer de faire
une bonne blague, une grosse blague qu'il avait toujours
essayée avec les petits mais il voulait en
faire une géante et alors il a inventé
cette créature et  il a conçu cette
créature dans sa tête, puis il a demandé
à quelqu'un de construire une forme de créature
à partir de cornes et de peaux de vache et il a obtenu
un liquide à très forte odeur provenant de l'
usine d'équarrissage de la région et il a
fini par créer ce monstre et ensuite
le montrer aux gens.  lui disant que c'était
la vraie chose qu'il avait découverte
dans les bois, que cela rappelait les
temps préhistoriques et que c'était sur la
planète depuis de très nombreuses années et que c'était
très féroce.
Le Smithsonian Institute a en fait envoyé
des gens ici et c'est à ce moment-là que Jean
Shepard a dû admettre que tout
cela était en effet une blague. Je pense que
Jean Shepherd est probablement, euh,
vous savez, l'un des premiers ambassadeurs
que nous avons eu pour la
communauté rhénane, il nous a en quelque sorte mis sur la carte
et il, euh, je  Je ne pense pas qu'il ait probablement jamais eu
l'intention de le faire et je pense qu'il a probablement
pensé que cela allait être hilarant
lorsque mes amis entendraient cette histoire sur
ce que je viens de découvrir, mais il
a certainement contribué à mettre Rhinelander sur
la carte et s'est fait un nom pour  notre
communauté
merci
[Musique]
Rhinelander hassanville MidWest America
est
[Musique]
en traversant la ville de
Rhinelander, vous verrez
des photos de l'œuf entier presque
partout où vous allez, y
compris de petites statues de
lui-même auxquelles
le Hodag a été associé  le
nom de Ryan Lander depuis plus de 100 ans
maintenant et d'après mon expérience, sa popularité a en quelque sorte
augmenté et diminué. Il y
a eu une période il y a 15 ou 20
ans où il y avait une controverse
quant à savoir s'ils devaient peindre le Hodag
sur l'un des  des châteaux d'eau parce que vous
savez, nous ne voulons pas que cette ville
soit connue pour rien d'autre que le Hodag
depuis lors, ils ont fait demi-tour et vous
savez le Hodag, il y a une
sculpture massive juste en face de la
Chambre de Commerce et c'est allumé  les
châteaux d'eau et les gens en sont fiers
euh et c'est absolument un attrait pour
les touristes parce que c'est la tradition d'
une époque révolue de la région du Bûcheron
qui remonte à seulement une centaine d'années,
c'était vraiment ce que cette ville dans la majeure partie
du Nord  Le Wisconsin a été construit grâce aux
gens qui viennent ici à Rhinelander et quand
ils viennent ici à Ryan Lander, l'une des
premières choses qu'ils font est de s'arrêter à la
Chambre de Commerce et de
se prendre en photo devant le
hodeig géant qui est l'un des principaux
attractions pour les Rhénans et
amène les gens ici parce qu'ils veulent
voir ce qu'est ce mythe du Hodag
cette histoire du hodeig comment s'est-il
développé où a-t-il été conservé comment a-t-il été
capturé et bien sûr ils ont besoin d'
en avoir une photo
[  Musique]
le Hodag est vraiment l'une des choses
que Rhinelander est connu pour beaucoup de
gens du Wisconsin si vous dites oh je viens
de Rhénanie ou j'habite en
Rhénanie, ils diront oh maison du
Hodag, nous connaissons le Hodag nous'  J'ai en quelque sorte
adopté l'idée que nous sommes les
œufs chauds de Rhénanie, c'est la mascotte de notre lycée.
Nous avons le festival country Hodag qui
est l'un des plus grands festivals country
de l'État, intégrant le Hodag dans
tout le reste, cela aide en quelque sorte à maintenir la
légende,
c'est très difficile.  pour fixer une date quand tu es
d'ici quand tu as entendu parler du
Hodag c'est autour de toi tout le temps c'est
sur chaque panneau c'est sur ton
concessionnaire de pneus c'est sur un restaurant c'est sur
tout donc ça commence en quelque sorte quand tu
commences l'
un des  Les grandes attractions touristiques que nous
avons ici, bien sûr, sont notre
festival de musique country Hodag, où nous réunissons de
nombreuses grandes stars de la musique country, puis nous
avons d'autres festivals qui ont
lieu. Les événements du centre-ville de Potato Fest
ne sont pas justes, ce sont toutes des choses.  qui se
déroulent à l'extérieur parce que nous avons
un si bel endroit à visiter
[Musique]
maintenant nous allons aller au Pioneer
Park qui contient le musée du bois
et dans le musée du bois il y a des
artefacts et des équipements qui étaient
utilisés au début  jours d'exploitation forestière
ici dans le nord du Wisconsin et
plus particulièrement dans la région rhénane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rappelez-vous
[Musique]
la foire du comté et le Hodag partagent une
histoire et nous voici en 2013 et le
Hodag est de retour à la foire du comté
bienvenue bienvenue  à la célèbre
exposition Hodag dans le monde entier et c'est un spectacle populaire
à la foire du comté, donc la boucle est bouclée 110
ans 120 ans plus tard, les hodags sont de retour en
ville qui sont ici pour voir toute la journée,
ouais, d'
accord
[Musique]
Étranger quand Jerry est arrivé pour la première fois  avec
son sketch ou en fait une reconstitution
de Gene Shepherd parlant du Hodag
à la foire originale du comté d'Oneida, euh, il
a joué ça à la dernière
foire du comté d'Oneida il y a un an et c'était un
Smash Hit si nous devions regarder le
cœur d'un hodag,  serait noir, c'est
à quel point cette créature est diabolique et sinistre,
les gens adorent la performance, ils
aiment le frisson de vous savez, nous
allons voir un Hodag Jerry est un grand
acteur et il en sait vraiment beaucoup
sur Gene Shepherd et il est moi  Je pense
qu'il a capturé en quelque sorte le sens du spectacle,
la qualité PT Barnum
de Gene Shepherd, donc vous savez que les gens ont
adoré le spectacle auquel ils affluaient. En
fait, je pense que pour leur représentation finale,
ils avaient quelques centaines de personnes
qui ne rentraient même pas dans la tente.
là où ils le jouaient, ils ont
dû ouvrir les volets
merci
pendant la reconstitution
nous avons le Carnival Barker qui
essaie de vendre un
produit particulier dans ce cas hodeg eau d'élixir magique
Madame une bouteille d'eau de mélangeur magique Hodag
pour votre mari et vous  J'aurai un
nouveau Boost dans celui de la nourriture, j'en prendrai un,
puis nous passerons directement à une
petite histoire sur la façon dont l'œuf entier
a été découvert et à une petite
description du Hodag de
manière humoristique.  L'émission de Jerry était très intéressante,
vu quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
un peu d'aide ici
et
je ne sais pas, c'était un peu étrange à
certains moments,
donc je pense que les gens ont adoré parce que c'était,
vous savez, une touche de médecine d'antan.
montrez l'histoire euh et et vous
savez, dans une certaine mesure, tout le monde a
hâte d'entrer dans la tente pour voir le
Hodag
sur la base d'un Carnival Sideshow si vous avez
déjà vu des films sur les vieux cirques
dans les vieilles foires à travers le pays, ils ont
toujours  avaient des spectacles, ils avaient toujours
ces choses uniques, les femmes barbus, les
grandes et les minces, les maigres et
les petites et tous ces
différents spectacles auxquels personne ne croyait
une minute mais ils étaient toujours amusants d'
écouter les aboyeurs parler
à ce sujet et puis c'était toujours amusant d'y
aller en sachant très bien que tu
allais probablement te faire arnaquer
[Musique]
alors nos déjeuners mais il y a des œufs chauds
ici en ville aussi pourquoi ce matin
quelqu'un a pris mes lunettes je pense que
c'était un tout  jour, dans la région rhénane, il
y a quelques années, nous avons utilisé la chasse au Hodag pour
une campagne de marketing et Chris Drees était
l'un de nos chasseurs de Hodag et nous avons fait
des publicités télévisées basées sur les
différents endroits où vous pouvez trouver le
Hodag, le Hodag est très connu pour
voler  des balles de golf par exemple
euh et donc nous sommes allés chasser le Hodag
sur le terrain de golf le Hodag aime aussi le
poisson frais, surtout le poisson du bout
de votre ligne de pêche, donc si ce gros poisson
s'échappe un jour, ce n'est pas vraiment que le
gros poisson s'est enfui  Hodag, vous le savez, est parti
nager et vous l'a pris.
Chris vous emmènera certainement à
la chasse au hodek et il est probablement l'un des
chasseurs Hodag experts que nous avons dans la région
et ce qui est amusant, c'est si vous pouvez
mettre la main sur  de lui et il se trouve qu'il est
libre, il n'y aura aucun frais et il
vous emmènera dans les endroits dans les
bois dans l'eau autour de la ville où le
Hodag est le plus connu pour être repéré et
vous avez les meilleures chances de le trouver
[Musique]
il n'y a jamais eu d'observation confirmée
du Hodag seulement,
euh,
vous connaissez les rumeurs que nous avons dans le
nord, alors quand je suis venu dans le nord du
Wisconsin, j'ai été intrigué comme beaucoup d'autres
personnes et j'ai commencé à faire
des recherches, vous savez, sur le camouflage.  C'est
très bien apparemment, comme nous pouvons le voir par
les œufs entiers que nous avons localement, les
verts
et les ombres sombres imitent
très bien notre forêt, ils peuvent écrire juste derrière
vous et vous saurez que le
pourcentage est beaucoup plus fort que celui de n'importe quel chien.
signalé, donc lorsque vous cherchez
toute la journée, vous devez vous laver les mains
très soigneusement,
très très soigneusement et vous devez prendre
un gant respiratoire car ils sentiront
votre haleine humaine à plus d'un kilomètre et
demi,
donc c'est probablement l'une des raisons pour lesquelles non
en fait, on a vu toute la journée
[Musique]
et c'est un très bon pays Hodag
et nous allons aussi dans une zone marécageuse
que la plupart des gens n'aiment pas, donc
les créatures qui vivent dans les marais
sont quelque peu protégées
des gens qui sont  pour les chercher,
vous devez chercher dans des endroits inhabituels pendant
toute la journée
cela a été fait et le bâton est cassé comme
vous pouvez le voir, cela a été fait par quelque chose,
que ce soit un œuf chaud ou un ours creusé,
mais il a été creusé pour une raison  c'est très
important
parce qu'ils étaient peut-être ici à
la recherche de racines
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que nous devrions réellement
chasser le Hodag parce que vous savez, si
vous sortez dans les bois, il pourrait y avoir,
euh, vous savez, il pourrait y avoir de vrais animaux  là-
bas, vous savez, il y aurait peut-être un
ours ou des moustiques ou quelque chose
comme ça et donc vous
savez, je pense juste que ce serait plus
de problèmes que cela n'en vaut la
peine, mais parfois vous savez si les invités
veulent traquer un t-shirt  avec un
œuf chaud dessus ou une tasse de café, vous savez
quelque chose comme ça, comme un souvenir d'œuf chaud,
je leur dirai où aller
parce qu'ils les vendent dans quelques
endroits de la ville et ils iront
les chercher et ils réussiront
à chaque fois dans cette chasse, je dirais qu'il
y a absolument un lien économique
entre le Hodag et le tourisme, car
même pour les gens dont les Rhénans ne sont peut-
être pas leur destination finale, cela signifie qu'ils
peuvent quand même prendre le déjeuner, ils vont
quand même essayer de ramener à la maison un
Souvenir de Hodag avec eux et disent qu'ils ont
vu le Hodag et se sont fait
prendre en photo. Gene Shepherd a gagné pas mal
d'argent il y a eu un week-end où il a
en fait eu un centime par pièce rapporté
500 dollars
maintenant 500 même aujourd'hui, c'est un joli petit
morceau  de monnaie à l'époque, c'était pas
mal d'argent, tout ce que vous pouvez
trouver sur des porte-
clés, euh, des autocollants pour pare-chocs. J'ai une petite
boule à neige avec le tout sur une
boule à neige, quiconque a un sens des
affaires utilise le Hodag pour
promouvoir leur entreprise nous avons des
sweat-shirts nous avons des T-shirts nous avons bien
sûr nous sommes dans le Wisconsin donc nous avons
des chopes à bière nous avons des histoires pour enfants donc
nous avons toute une gamme de produits
appelés Happy the Hodag qui a été créée
par une femme qui est à l'origine  de
Rhinelander et donc Happy est la
version la plus adaptée aux enfants de la
fenêtre Hodag s'accroche aux autocollants pour pare-chocs
cartes postales, vous l'appelez si nous pouvons mettre un
Hodag dessus, nous essaierons
merci
Gene Shepherd a découvert un animal féroce et sinistre très maléfique
qui puait jusqu'au ciel
au fil des années pour s'adapter et
adopter une mascotte à l'époque actuelle il
fallait qu'elle soit un peu plus conviviale
[Musique]
et l'école du lycée
Rhinelander High School en a fait la
mascotte et ce fut le début de
beaucoup de changements  avec le Hodag parce que
le Hodag était un vrai monstre avant ça
euh tu voulais faire peur aux gens avec le
Hodag mais après après que l'école l'a
adopté c'est devenu bien c'est huit
bouledogues blancs au lieu de chair humaine et seulement
le dimanche il mangeait les bouledogues blancs
donc il a été beaucoup nettoyé
et il y a une histoire sur la façon dont le
Hodag noir du nord est devenu vert c'est une
histoire simple Le lycée rhénan
avait des uniformes de football verts,
ils ont repeint l'œuf entier,
c'était une chose terrible pour la pauvre
bête qui a grandi ici  en Rhénanie euh,
le hodeig a toujours fait partie de notre famille
et nous en sommes tous très fiers, il a
grandi et grandi le soutien pour le code,
c'est juste merveilleux donc il est passé
du noir au vert et de féroce
et maléfique à un peu plus sympathique
merci  toi
mystérieux
[Musique]
étrangère
emmène les enfants et quel genre de
choses amusantes ils pourraient faire en cherchant
le hodek nous venons ici depuis
des années pour essayer d'en trouver un
ouais, j'ai aussi vu le  Hodag est
utilisé comme outil parental dans la mesure où ils
diront à leurs enfants que vous savez que vous voudrez
peut-être faire attention, vous comporter et
rester dans la tente s'ils campent
ce soir, car le Hodag pourrait
potentiellement vous faufiler hors des
bois ou sortir de  le lac et c'est
toujours génial quand les enfants ont les yeux très
grands et qu'ils entendent ce qui pourrait
arriver quand ils n'écoutent pas maman et
papa
[Musique]
merci
là-bas
quoi de neuf
Elizabeth [
Musique]
Wisconsin unique
[Musique]
les gens se demandent comment il se fait que l'
œuf entier soit vivant après plus de cent ans
et bien il y a plusieurs raisons, la principale
étant que c'est une créature unique il
n'y a pas d'autres mascottes qui ressemblent au
Hodag qui existe comme le Hodag il n'y
a pas d'autres créatures  qui ont un mythe
et une histoire construits autour d'eux au fil du
temps et qui ne cesse de prendre de l'
ampleur.
USA Today a organisé un concours où vous pouviez
voter en ligne dans le Wisconsin. Nous étions
considérés comme la mascotte la plus unique de l'
État,
c'est donc une histoire absolument merveilleuse.
et un grand grand nom d'une
créature que beaucoup de gens ont
exploité et qui ont
continué avec le mythe
[Musique]
Le mystère du hodad, je dis que
je l'ai fait et donc, que vous le
croyiez ou non, c'est  un
peu comme le Père Noël, je pense que vous savez,
les enfants croiront toujours au Père Noël
jusqu'à ce qu'on leur dise le contraire, alors
euh, nous traitons le Hodag de la
même manière que
le chagrin d'amour nous donne plus, je
veux dire, fait que
cela fait de la ville un  plus cool, je ne
sais pas, j'essaie
d'expliquer cela, cela apporte une
reconnaissance au ton de
Rhinelander et ensuite nous pouvons faire des
t-shirts à ce sujet et le vendre.
Je pense que c'est un excellent crochet initial. Je
pense que les gens s'y mettent vraiment.
je pense qu'ils viennent ici, ils
aiment ça ici, ils passent un bon moment et
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de Hodag à la
fin de la journée n'a vraiment pas d'importance,
c'est aussi réel que vous voulez le faire
et les enfants adorent ça, je veux dire  nous avons des
livres d'histoires à ce sujet, euh,
ils ont fait un épisode de Scooby-Doo à ce sujet,
donc dans Rhinelander Hearts, c'est réel, c'est
réel pour nous tous
étrangers
[Musique]
au fil des ans parce que nous avons
si bien adouci l'image du hodek que
c'est  juste une créature plus adorable, plus douce,
plus intéressante à adopter et
à aimer et donc les gens l'ont adopté
si vous voulez croire que
vous croirez qu'en fin de compte
c'est amusant c'est toute la mystique
derrière la créature le Hodag la tradition
du  Bûcherons du 19ème siècle et
je veux y croire tu vas le croire
[Musique] [
Musique]
merci
étranger
[Musique]